Hi this is Presh Talwalkar
How predictable are you?
Lets find out in this video.
In front of you are the numbers 1 through 16
To get started, I want you to pick a number
You can pick any of these sixteen numbers
But you should remember which number you've picked
It might help if you circled it
as you'll need to remember this number for the rest of the video.
Now I want you to pick a second number.
And I want one condition: I want that number to be in a different row
and a different column from the first number you've picked.
So if you picked the number 10 as your first number,
the next number you pick should not be in the same row,
and it should not be in the same column.
So you can pick from any of the remaining numbers
that are not in the same row and the same column as the first number you've picked
I also want you to remember this number
so remember the first number you've picked
and the second number you've picked
You're gonna repeat this process: pick a third number
that's in a different row and a different column
from the first two numbers you've picked.
So you don't want this number to be in the same row
or the same column as either of the first two numbers you've picked.
So now you've picked THREE different numbers
and I want you to remember them
because you're gonna have to do one more thing
I want you to pick a fourth number
that's also in a different row and in a different column.
from the previous three number you've picked.
So if you've followed along correctly,
you've now picked FOUR numbers,
and you played according to the rules where they are in different
rows or in different columns
so your numbers might end up looking something like this.
So you've got your four numbers
and I want you to ADD up these four numbers
so there's no way I could've known what first number
you've picked, or the second number was, or third or the fourth.
But now here comes a prediction.
Add up those four numbers you have
and here is what my prediction is:
My prediction is the sum of your numbers is 34.
Am I correct?
If you want to know how this trick works,
you can follow a link in the video description
where I describe the mathematical proof
in a blog post.
Thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel, I make videos on math and game theory,
you can catch me on my blog: MindYourDecisions
which you can follow on Facebook, Google+ and Patreon.
You can catch me on social media @PreshTalwalkar
And if you like the video, please check out my books
There is a detailed description of each book in the video description.